we all know what it feels like to be on
a team where we are offered
psychological safety it means that we
can raise our hands and say I made a
mistake or I don't understand or I've
got some stuff going on at home and it's
affecting my work or I need help or can
you please be patient with me when we
can say these things
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution
um we can say these things without any
fear that will hurt our promotability
but more important we can say these
things with the confidence that those in
our team will rush in to support us or
our leaders will rush in to support us
and this is a huge factor for employee
burnout because when we feel that we can
say those things and we can feel
supported and we're more likely to seek
help for whatever is stressing us out or
causing us anxiety and more importantly
we don't feel alone as we're going
through the stress that's leading to
burnout so absolutely psychological
safety is a big part of helping reduce
employee burnout